good morning
um welcome to the legislative
Administration it's nine o'clock we like
to start on time I'm going to ask our
representative turcott to lead us in the
pledge
of the United States of America and to
the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God indivisible with
liberty and justice for all
um no housekeeping that I'm aware of to
start off
um I do see
that we are going to be hearing three
bills this morning beginning at nine
um actually we're starting with the cacr
uh then we go to two bills
uh there'll be a little break for us
somewhere between the second and third
one
um if everyone's good with that
sure
some note-taking gonna take place I
guess
um good morning
um represent uh Senator Susie if you'd
like to join us at the witness table
welcome to the legislative
Administration certainly thank you Mr
chairman and members of the committee
for the record I'm Donna soucy I
represent Senate District 18 comprised
of five Wards of the city of Manchester
in the town of
um cacr-10 is an attempt to resolve what
has been a question that for my many
years of service I felt the need to
answer for members I want to make very
clear from the outset this in no way
involves organization day so this does
not involve the legislative functions
that happen in December those remain in
the Constitution as they were drafted
the issue comes around the time of the
governor's inauguration
right now the language of the
Constitution provides that the
legislature must meet
on the first Wednesday in January
and the governor's inauguration happens
on Thursday
for the house I understand there are
times where there is some business
conducted and and that's fine in the
Senate we literally convene on the
Wednesday because the Constitution says
we have to convene we convene for no
reason
it lasts about five minutes it requires
publicity publication of notice it
requires staff time requires payment of
mileage
and the function that is anticipated is
something that goes back to the days of
horse and buggy and that was canvassing
the vote for the office of Governor
um I dare say that the resolution of the
gubernatorial election occurs long
before
we assemble in January and the function
is more celebratory in nature it's more
perfunctory so what the amendment would
do is have the
um
have the legislature meet on the
Thursday and I want to make very very
clear this does not preclude additional
meetings should the bodies choose to
meet
Tuesday Wednesday Monday or Friday of
that week that's that's up to the bodies
to determine but what I'm trying to do
is eliminate the need to meet on both
Wednesday and Thursday when there really
isn't an absolute function of the
legislature on Wednesday and I think
it's a matter of efficiency and a fair
question to put before the voters with
that I'd be happy to answer any
questions thank you
representative Constable did you not say
that you had 35 questions for uh each
one of these
I have uh I have one or two
um if you don't mind
um
I'm seeing by the the list of sponsors
and and with two exceptions
um it seems to be and and because this
has come out of the Senate I'm wondering
if if this is
um more for the
convenience of the Senate than it is the
Mr chairman it would apply it would
apply to either chamber but I it is my
understanding and I know the clerk is
here the house sometimes does conduct
other business on that day before I'm
not trying to preclude the house from
doing that
um the house could meet a little earlier
on Thursday and do the same business if
it deems appropriate if not the house
could meet on Wednesday but what I'm
trying to do is eliminate the Wednesdays
being an absolute
okay so it may it may functionally
disproportionately impact the Senate
than it does the house but it in no way
dictates that the chamber couldn't meet
if the house should choose to I see
um I may have misspoken and said
convenience is it also a fiscal issue
and have you calculated there's
obviously no fiscal note with this but
is there is there was that part of the
consideration for the bill as well to
the extent that it requires two days in
a row of all members be ERS Byzantine
Concord
hacked um if it were passed by the
voters it would cost the state of New
Hampshire a bit less because you
wouldn't be convening and therefore
wouldn't be paying mileage
okay
um you you wouldn't know uh offhand a
the amount that we're talking about I I
wouldn't but I could attempt to uh get
the no just wondered whether that came
up in any of the conversations uh in the
Senate side
did you um
I don't mean to if there are questions
if anyone wants to just pop in that's
great with me
um
when this was heard in the Senate
what reaction did you receive from the
from the public on this was uh there
wasn't much public reaction I don't
think it's something that the public is
keenly aware of I think it's it's more
an internal function obviously the
question of whether to make this change
or not would be determined by the public
because it requires a vote
um but there was unanimous support in
the Senate
um for the Constitutional Amendment
because we see it as I said as an
efficiency a convenience
um
the language goes back a long long time
when our elections were conducted
differently and as I said you know
ballots were probably delivered by horse
and buggy at that time
um so this is just an update to what I
think is some very old language that
doesn't reflect our current practices
um gubernatorial elections as we know we
have the results the night of the
election and if there is any dispute
very quickly following that those
disputes would be resolved through
recount or through the other legal
processes that we have so I once again I
would just ask that you look favorably
upon this I am not trying in any way to
preclude uh the work the house may
choose to do the day before the
governor's inauguration but I do want to
emphasize we will be organized as we
typically are in December I'm in no way
impacting any of that with the drafting
of this amendment great
uh further question yes representative
McCarter
good morning thank you
um
did you
I I apologize for being a little tardy
so you may have already covered this
um was this something that
um
you were approached by outside of either
the senate or the legislature
to present as a bill or did you decide
to do this because you saw an issue that
needs to be rectified
thank you representative I saw an issue
that I thought needed to be addressed
and in speaking with Senate colleagues
at the time from from both parties uh
there was
agreement as you can see from the
sponsors here there was significant
agreement that this is something that
made a lot of sense
brother follow-up no all set
um the only question I
I didn't pass a a group of protesters on
the way in here for uh for this
obviously and I and I'm I am
although I'm searching for it in vain
the language that would be on the ballot
when I first read it
seemed a little awkward and I always
question whether
it would get full play
um you know anytime people see the first
Thursday following the second Tuesday of
the
um it that's about as far as most people
go on the question so
I'm concerned that it would get
on the ballot here it is are you in
favor of amending articles 3 4 42 66 to
read as follows
um
when when the House and Senate shall
assemble biannually on the first
Wednesday in December for organizational
days
and shall assemble annually on the first
Thursday following the first Wednesday
in January
that's where I think most
of our voters will stop
I'm I'm wondering
how
we should think
if we only have
30 people that finally that follow this
kind of process vote on it which may be
all of the Senators that vote on that
day and you know six members of the
public is that
a good reason for us to change how we
operate
with so few people paying attention on
I think it's always good to examine how
we operate to find efficiencies in this
case if it were a statute Mr chairman it
would be easy and we would all you know
I think perhaps not our heads okay this
makes sense let's make this change
yeah
I mean the Constitution is a document
that we have had to amend for various
reasons this committee probably consider
or maybe Judiciary considered the issue
around probate
and registers of probate and there's
language about the sheriff and a lot of
the languages are cane it's just given
that we are one of the oldest States one
of the first states to form there is
language in our Constitution that dates
back more than 200 years and
you're correct Mr chair I I agree with
your assessment that it may not be
language that's easily digested by the
general public but I I don't see that as
an impediment to putting the question
forward and for folks like myself and
others to communicate about what this
would do just recently the Senate did
pass the Constitutional Amendment the
representative Lynn and I sponsored to
put the issue of updating the judicial
retirement age before the voters this
would be another question and I think
given that there could be the potential
for more than one question
um there could be more activity and more
discussion to inform voters about what
these important issues are so that they
can make those decisions come November
24th November of 2024 pardon me great
thank you very much up we do have one
addition thank you Mr chairman thank you
very much for coming in today I'm still
trying to to grasp what improvements
would we see from this in the function
of the house or even the governor's
office do we see something changing in a
positive way
what we would see is that instead of
that first week in January both bodies
convening on both Wednesday and Thursday
we would convene we would only be
thank you thank you because as I said
over many years I was frequently asked
the question what is it that we're doing
here why are we will the Constitution
requires us to be here and that's why on
Wednesday both bodies assemble as I said
if if one chamber or both choose to meet
on that Tuesday or Wednesday nothing
precludes them from meeting
this just eliminates a requirement to me
both days
but you would see
you believe that if if the requirement
was removed for speaking on or for
attending on both days you believe that
one or both houses would
someone would only meet on one day yes
okay I believe at least one all right if
not both all right
but I don't I don't speak on behalf of
the house
any more than any of us speak for the
Senate right thank you very much
um I think we're all set appreciate your
bringing this to us thank you have a
we have only one other pink card
um brought To Us by uh
welcome
thank you Mr chairman for the record
this is my favorite committee uh Paul
Smith Clerk of the house uh testifying
on behalf of the speaker of the house
today uh who is opposed to the cacr I
want to make it clear the Constitution
does not require us to meet on two
separate days at this point it does not
require us to meet on two separate days
at this point that being said I want to
give you some some history I asked Myla
Patton in the research office the
question regarding convening day being
separated from the installation of the
governor she assembled information that
showed the convening of the legislature
occurred sometime before but in many
cases the day before or in the case of
1784 the president's inauguration during
the following years and she used this on
a decade by decade basis 1784 18 19 1885
1897 1899 1903 1913 1923 1933 1943 1953
1963 1973 1983 so that's just a brief
snap snapshot of when it it is either a
day before or in the case of
1819 it was a week and a half before
so the practical
convening day is a work day for the
House of Representatives
I want to be clear we go into joint
convention
because that is required by the
Constitution we go into joint convention
with the Senate uh hear the report from
the Secretary of State
and there's there's one important piece
here and yes it hasn't been used but
if a plurality for governor isn't
attained
it is up to the general court in joint
session convened to determine the winner
so that's an important part of that
joint convention
after we hear the Secretary of State's
report we adjourn and usually spend the
next several hours discussing amendments
to house rules that will impact us for
the biennium on the top of our
introduction of normal house bills
the next day the house convenes we come
in for joint convention and go into the
governor's inauguration immediately
adjourn why do we do this well beyond
the usual custom usage and precedent
that you hear from me it's the
governor's day and as she or he is
required to be sworn in in the presence
of both houses can consistent with part
two article 85 we have historically
opted to give the governor extensive use
of the chamber and galleries for guests
civil servants and family members while
accommodating the members of the house
and the Senate who wish to be there
it's important to note we do not take
votes on inauguration day those wishing
to not attend don't have absences
the Senate has in modern times opted not
to be in session beyond their
constitutionally mandated meeting with
us on convening day typically they
handle their deadlines on organization
day having worked that out among their
testimony smaller chamber and their
rules don't change as frequently as ours
do
so from their perspective this certainly
makes sense they don't have the work to
do so why not just come in for one day
the reality is with the house working a
full day we could accommodate the
centuries-old practice but
it would mean essentially that we would
not provide any space for the new
governor for the purposes of the
inauguration and frankly by the letter
of the Constitution we are also not
required to accept an address from the
governor at that point though we have
also maintained that centuries-old
practice as well as entering them into
our Journal
so let me be clear we could do this all
on one day bring the governor in have
the Chief Justice swear them in the
presence of the house and the Senate and
immediately invite the governor to leave
so that we can do our business
but again historically we have opted not
to do that because courtesy between
branches
the bottom line is that a quorum of the
Senate which is 13 is all that is
necessary to show and arrive on those
two January dates if they don't have any
other legislative business requiring
their attention
if this amendment goes to the voters
technically I'm not sure that most folks
understand the terminology in fact as
the chair brought up the
uh
provision last year regarding the
registers of probate it was a confusing
language it failed
closely because of the confusing
language I received many calls in my
office from voters I spent 45 minutes on
the phone uh with the lady representing
the league of conference conservation
voters trying to explain the the Nuance
of the detail and that's not my job uh
to be honest but I I do wonder about uh
how this is is worded
and I I think beyond the 24 who
obviously would benefit from this change
I don't think the 400 in this chamber
would
so again on behalf of the speaker uh he
is opposed to the cacr
ify thank you Mr clerk um any you will
nothing
yes sure
this is just for explanation for me I'm
also a selectman in Northumberland
and page
two line three uh change at line five
that the Selectmen of all town cities
Wards and plate and places in the state
are directed to in certain their
warrants
are you
I've never done a warrant for a general
election that I can recall
the ballots are sent to us
uh and it wouldn't be at our town
meeting because that's in March
what are we being told to do
I think the the correct person to ask
that question of would be the sponsor
okay
because it's not written in italics so
that um as I understand it that's
that's not being changed that's existing
language so that may be something that
we wanna
take up with
secretary of state that that's the
question I basically got is
as far as I know we don't do that
well
um again we'll um we'll
we'll inquire of the Secretary of State
and see if we can get us some
information for you on that
um
and that somewhat does go to to the
point
that that a lot of this section
um
is internal language for how we operate
the one piece that you've pulled out
here
does affect the rest of the state but
generally what we're bringing up in this
or what the sponsor is bringing up in
this amendment is dealing with our
internal organization so
um I think I think we'll get an answer
to that but we'll get it outside the
scope of this this amendment
um I have just a just a
follow up on some of the the points that
you've made yes sir um
I don't think I was aware that only that
we need a quorum of just 13 Senators to
participate so it would be possible
if if they are concerned about having
two days
consecutively it is possible that they
could alternate and some group come one
year some come another year if they
wanted to right is that right so for for
the the purposes of a joint convention
we resolve ourselves both bodies into
meeting together in joint conventions so
the the house adopts a resolution the
Senate adopts a resolution as well uh in
order to adopt a simple resolution uh
for those purposes only requires a
quorum to do so uh so that that uh you
know how they chose to to do it is is
entirely up to them if if the 24 uh
wanted to be in for the purposes of the
initial I would I would just state that
convening day joint convention
is a very simple one it goes very
quickly it consists of the house
resolving into the joint convention the
Senate resolving into joint convention
we exchanged messages we introduced the
Senate we hear the report from the
Secretary of State we form the committee
and we exit The Joint convention it's
usually
I think frankly it might take longer
introducing and getting the senator
seated than the the actual uh report of
numbers by the Secretary of State then
the following day when we go into joint
convention
um we come in to the Joint convention uh
we we review the report of the committee
and then we go into the actual uh
inauguration but again similar to the
house
not all Senators attend on the
inauguration it uh this this year Alone
um you know many many many members of
the House did not attend uh the
inauguration this year um
we we often as I mentioned do give up
extensive amounts of seating on the
floor to accommodate the the department
heads and and family and guests of the
governor-elect uh it is a courtesy
um and that is why we also opt not to
take other actions that day so that
requiring members to be there is not
you know a true function in in that
sense we don't we don't hold votes to to
count against folks so
but we could
um
given that there's a need for some
Senators on on the first day and some
Senators on the second day
it is possible for them
to um
on their own break into two different
groups and one attend one day and one to
ten this second day there's no there's
no requirement that the same Senator
that attends on the first day also
attend on the second day there's nothing
like that in here I I will I will I
would never I would never ever dare
question the the rules and and decision
making of the other body I understand
I'm just saying from a practical
purpose it is it is entirely within
their
purview to be able to accommodate
the Senators who may not wish to drive
both days or come here both days it is
possible within this current situation
for them to just handle one day or the
other and as I said Mr chairman just to
be clear we could right now
we could right now
inaugurate the governor on convening day
there is no prohibition against that
okay
yes thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for your explanations I'm still trying
to
see the real problem here
um logistically this could be a
nightmare couldn't it because I'm I I
was at the last inauguration has it been
at the others you're right a lot of
house members did not attend but usually
an awful lot of people come in for the
Governor's Inauguration so if we had
this all on the same day the way this
bill is suggesting the cacr rather
um this could be logistically very
awkward for seating couldn't it well
again we so if this were to happen
during a regular session day uh we would
not afford the governor uh the space on
certainly on the floor because we would
then go into a regular session
thereafter to do our work
um and and as I said uh over the the
last many years we have spent hours on
convening day arguing rules changes
um sometimes we have a few is I don't
know half a dozen amendments to rules
but sometimes we have
20. so it it can take a while and I
obviously I note
um you know in the unfortunate
circumstance uh during covid on January
6 2021 uh when we were at the parking
lot session at UNH we also had to elect
a new speaker that day
um so I mean that it is a it is a day of
follow up Mr chairman yeah um it may or
may not be relevant to this but um how
do other states do it does that matter
to any of this or what are the practices
I it doesn't matter I I well that's
that's it for you to determine uh if it
matters or not
um I can only speak to our perspective
follow up thank you um
so if we were to pass this
what impact might this have on the work
that we're trying to do that day
would it
complicate things would it make our work
longer I'm trying to again grasp the
problem sure well I I mean certainly as
as you folks are all expertly aware
um the the house will do the work that
it needs to do uh as long as it needs to
be done
um I would suggest uh that in in the
situation
um there is no obligation to provide the
governor the opportunity to have an
inaugural address in the chamber it
simply requires the governor to be sworn
in front of both houses and that's what
the uh the Constitution currently says
so that's why
yeah you know I I do think logistically
for for the house it would be a longer
more difficult day and
you know especially because as as you
are aware as well uh we usually convene
it's sort of an interesting time to
accommodate a certain time frame where
certain things are broadcast on certain
news networks
um and and that that usually plays into
the timing of the inauguration as well
so you know in in reality what would
likely happen if we were sharing a day
we would come in do a little bit of work
then Sort of hope that work was done at
an exact time so that we can recess and
you know accommodate the the other
things
Senator McCarter
thank you
um
Clerk
do you have any kind of a an attendance
record for
our convening day
as compared to inauguration day you may
not have it handy but is that something
easily accessible
so if you look at the the journals of
the house
um on at the beginning of each Journal
because the journal is a reflection of
what happens on the floor so people call
out
for the day they are listed under the
excused absences part of the journal
right at the beginning and on convening
day you will see that because it is a an
actual session day there are a lot less
historically than on inauguration day
and then again even on inauguration day
if people call
and tell me they're not coming they'll
be listed but that doesn't mean that
everybody calls so you know
follow up
so let's uh explore it this way let's
say that we had all of this happen on
the same day and convening day
obviously most people show up not all
but most
then the governor would be precluded
from having a lot of people there
supporting him or her or uh just I don't
know observing it would be it would
cause a logistical issue in your opinion
well for as I mentioned it is a courtesy
of the house that we afford seating on
the floor for the Governor's family
important dignitaries and department and
agency heads and then Gallery space as
well if this is going to happen during
an actual session day we would not
afford any floor space and frankly the
gallery would become kind of first come
first serve
it's a courtesy
um you know it
we we we do try to
um even though the legislation
legislative branch is the first Branch
enumerated in the Constitution and the
best
um the governor is a is a co-equal
partner in government as is the court
representative Tierney I did want to
just address your question um I did
receive a text message from our our
legal counsel
um that uh
regarding your question uh it is
boilerplate language that that specific
section because right now it does direct
the towns to put it on the ballot not
not a special meeting but it does the
Constitution does require the towns to
on the ballots announce uh what the
elections are that's that's just a quick
text message that I received I don't
have any more details than that
okay I didn't think we had anything to
do with the ballot I mean they all come
from here to us we don't print them
ourselves so okay thank you of course
thank you Mr chair and uh thank you Mr
Claire for taking a question I just want
to put this to bed in my head so the the
language the the sponsor said was that
we can meet Wednesday
um it doesn't preclude us from meeting
on Wednesday but in my head what I I
don't show up for the uh the governor so
no I I've never done that I I give my
seat up I let someone else have my seat
I don't show up I show up on the day
that I need to and then the governor has
his day
but I sort of envisioned we would need
to show up both days to be able to give
the governor his time
and also to give us time to do our
business because I can't imagine that we
would just say to the governor like
you know
go scratch you know what I mean so we
would we would give him time as a
courtesy but also we would need time to
do our business so I'm envisioning that
I would actually have to show up both
days
and so in in on a Wednesday and a
Thursday and then in that point you know
for the convenience of the 24 Senators
it's like a severe inconvenience for the
400 legislators to show up
um whereas you know I'm only showing up
on one day currently
um I can't I I guess the question is can
you envision us having to both show up
on both days
um as the as a as a body to to
accommodate and then and therefore
instead of me giving up my seat I have
to be there both days
so I guess the answer to that question
um in my in my opinion
it's it's hard for me to Envision coming
early coming in earlier than convening
day because the whole notion of
convening means that we're starting
organization means we organize convening
means we're convening in beginning so to
to come in before that seems um
a I I'm fairly certain that that has
never happened that we've come in that
first Tuesday in January
because the Constitution since 1784 is
the first Wednesday after the first
Tuesday in January so I don't think that
we've ever come in well I shouldn't say
it it's been that way since 1784 because
we used to meet in June so
um but that being said it I
I would struggle to to think that we
would cut come in before actual
convening day
um
just just for a reminder's sake um
what what day are we doing the Secretary
of State and treasurer that by the
Constitution is on organization
organization day so constitutionally on
organization day the new house
assembles Alexis officers we go into
join convention to elect the Secretary
of State and State Treasurer and then we
go
out of session we and we adjourn from
that session
you couldn't Envision or we've never had
three
convening days
um
or three days during that time period
where we weren't able to handle the
amendments to our rules or anything like
that was it
this is again I I don't I don't want to
speak to Senate practice but as I
mentioned and they will acknowledge they
don't change their rules as regularly as
we do we actually have a Rules meeting
later in December a full full-on Rules
meeting where any member brings their
amendments uh it's time for uh testimony
to come Etc so
on top of that is
the selections of of seating and parking
and committee assignments and and I just
to to have a session during that time
um is very unlikely uh especially as
we're administratively trying to set up
the new biennium
right
thank you I think we're all set I
appreciate your testimony um do you have
any of that in writing that we can leave
for the fight I have some notes uh that
I've scribbled I can I think it would be
helpful if you would uh provide us I
will I will email the clerk accordingly
Mr chairman appreciate it
if you need instructions how to do that
thanks very much
um we're about 10 minutes over
um anyone see any reason I don't uh to
close the hearing on
um on Amendment on the cacr-10 and open
the hearing immediately on SB 28 you see
the prime sponsor
coughing in our presence I hope you're
feeling better we both were
uh crippled last week with yeah I don't
think you want that on YouTube but
um
thank you
welcome to uh Senator bird cell
um appreciate you coming and speaking to
thank you for hearing my bill Senate
Bill 28 for the record my name is Regina
Birdsall I'm the state senator for
district 19 which encompasses the towns
of dairy Hampstead in Windham and I am
the prime sponsor of Senate Bill 28 and
basically very simply this bill provides
that the joint legislative historical
committee May accept a gift of a
portrait of Rogers Johnson and for those
of you who don't know Rogers Johnson
um and I I'm sure Ani behind me will
talk about him as well
Rogers Johnson Rogers Jason Johnson
entered public service in New Hampshire
2001 serving as a New Hampshire State
Rep from event from then until 2006 and
during that time he became the state's
first African-American House Majority
Whip was awarded the black America's
political action committee Leaders of
Tomorrow award in 2004.
the New Hampshire Healthcare Association
award for long-term care service in 2003
and the New Hampshire Business Council
recognition support of small businesses
in 2003.
he was then asked by a former President
George W bush to go to Washington D.C
where he became director of
intergovernmental Affairs for the U.S
Department of Education a position that
he held until 2009.
he returned to New Hampshire he filled
numerous roles including policy advisors
speech writer and campaign manager for
various political campaigns he worked
with many different Civic public law
enforcement and professional
organizations to bring everyone together
in an effort to resolve diversity issues
that affected our communities the most
most recently he was chair of the
governor's advisory Council on diversity
and inclusion in New Hampshire and
served
on the New Hampshire Governor's covid-19
Equity response team and the commission
on law enforcement accountability
community and transparency and served as
treasurer of the New England Conference
of the end
NCAA n a
NAACP
[Laughter]
and was president of the Seacoast naw
NAACP working tirelessly on efforts
including Pass Key legislation for
vulnerable populations and with law
enforcement he did pass away
um
last year and I might add that Rogers
Johnson when I was first decided to run
for the state senate he was my go-to
person for Health Care issues uh what
was happening in the state of New
Hampshire because he was highly
knowledgeable about the health care
issues so he is
um
he is a man above all and I'd appreciate
a positive vote on Senate bill 28. I'll
take any questions thank you Senator did
I hear that you there already is this
portrait or this would be we're just
we're um they we can accept funds for
portrait to be done
I believe correct
well we'll find out
are there any questions for the senator
I see one representative Tierney
thank you for taking my question senator
is this required for the historical
commission to accept anything do we have
to do this every single time something
okay follow up
wouldn't it be better if we just gave
them permission
to
accept donations
versus having to come through with a
separate bill anytime somebody wishes to
make a donation
that would be another bill that we could
put in to allow allow the organization
to accept donations but for the time
being this is the
procedure we have okay thank you
seeing no further questions will let you
get back to your recovery thanks very
much Senator thank you
the only other pink card I have
um
is for the from the executive director
for Human Rights Commission
um
Ms Malachi
welcome to the legislative
Administration
thank you very much
um chairman and thank you very much to
the committee for allowing me to be here
with you this morning
um just a few statements and then happy
to answer any questions you might have
as you stated I am the executive
director of the New Hampshire commission
for human rights I am also currently the
chair of the governor's advisory Council
just a few words about Rogers as Senator
Birdsall stated he was definitely a
friend to all people were not allowed to
be strangers around him and he made sure
to help anyone that would reach out to
him on any topic and if he didn't have
the answer he always knew who to point
you in the direction of so that you
could get said information but it was
rare that he didn't already have an
answer the
the part that's also important Rogers
was a commissioner for the Human Rights
Commission he served as a commissioner
from 2003 to 2008 and from 2003 to 2005
he was the interim chair for the
commission and um and as Senator
Birdsall stated
Rogers was the first chair of the
diversity and inclusion Council in 2017
when it was created by executive order
by governor sununu and he remained the
chair until his passing in 2020.
um although I am excited to be the chair
of the council I am also sad that I'm
the chair of the council because that
means he's not here to be the chair of
the council and someone that I can reach
out to to ask whatever kind of question
about anything from how bills become a
law or I don't understand this
conference of committee committee of
conference can you explain that please
from those questions to anything
happening in the world today
um
so it is a heavy heart a bit of cold
comfort to potentially have a portrait
of him here at the state house but also
a way to be able to pass by and and just
kind of wave and his wife was Poppy
Johnson she was uh very helpful in
kicking this off when the legislative
session started and I believe she's
watching via YouTube this morning so
good morning poppy
um and uh and their and their children
um Jay and Jeremy I know at least one of
them is possibly streaming with her at
home as well so
um she would have loved to have been
here but the travel and it it's it's
hard right she's lost the love of her
life and although we've lost a friend
but the the family has lost
significantly more I think the relevance
of having his portrait in the State
House speaks volumes it we already know
about based on what Senator broad so
read the amount of of uh Public Service
Human Service that Rogers did over the
course of his life and that's I'm sure
just a mere scratching of the surface
you know every phone call every hello
every pet on the shoulder every kind
word those things are not listed in a
bio or an obituary but it's carried in
the hearts of the people that he knew
and those people who knew others who
shared those stories so he is a a little
actually a big rock in our little Pond
of New Hampshire but he made a mighty
wave and spread across a wide girth of
of the state
so I'm excited to be here to share this
information with you and at this point
I'll close my statements and I'm happy
to answer any questions that you might
have thank you
thank you Ms Malachi uh
this is I'm glad this is a recording on
on YouTube I um I will go back and and
save the tape and and remember uh some
great lines that you used in there the
one that hit me most was uh not allowed
to be strangers around him that that is
absolutely true
um and uh and I'm also appreciative that
uh you pointed out that the Johnson
family is is watching on YouTube
um nice shout out to the to the Johnson
family
um representative wall thank you Mr
chairman thank you very much for coming
in and telling us so much
um I could look it up but since you're
here what years did he serve in the
house and what committee or committees
did he serve on do you recollect you
know what that's an excellent question I
know
um I may have it here I believe
somewhere around 2006 he was in the
house I do not remember the exact length
of time
um
no it was in 2006 because he was asked
by
when
I was halfway there 2001 to 2006. before
that's what I thought
about health matters yes so we we think
HHS thank you
Community thought I appreciate that
phone a friend right absolutely yes
thanks very much
um do we have
further questions not seeing none thank
you very much I'm sorry just a moment if
I could there was a question that you
asked representative Tierney regarding
the accepting um of a donation and the
the legislation needed to be provided to
receive permission to hang the portrait
at the state house so we can't we could
go the com the diversity and inclusion
council could raise money and have a
beautiful portrait done but without
permission from the legislators to hang
the portrait and in the state house we
would not be able to do that so that's
part of what this process is
okay thank you very much you're welcome
is there a timeline that
that we know of the length of time
before this portrait would be available
um no not as of yet we are looking uh at
different artists to be able to to
create the portraiture uh but even prior
to that there needs to be a fundraising
campaign but the decision was made by
the group at the diversity and inclusion
Council not to begin raising funds until
we had permission to to chicken array
thing here so no cart before the horse I
like that better
um thanks uh do you have written
testimony for our clerk um I do not but
we're good thanks very much again for
for taking the time and coming to speak
with us
um no other questions but appreciate it
very much thank you all very much have a
excuse me no other pink cards do I see
um so I will close the hearing on SB 28
and we have about
25 minutes before
um Senator Bill
84.
we'll be in recess until 10 15.
it is 10 15.
um
I'm going to open up the hearing on
Senate bill 84.
um the prime sponsor of this bill
doesn't look to be here but so I will
okay all right Senator gray uh welcome
my name is James Gray I represent Senate
District Six which starts up in Alton
and gilmington and goes down Route 11 to
um the reason that I'm here is I
hijacked this bill
okay
up pure and simple
I had a a need that I needed to take
care of
um and that was how we were doing
committees and commissions that was
stuck into I believe it's house bill 2.
which started restricting the number of
people that we could put on there
how many could be on a committee or
commission and as we started to write
bills this year
and set up those committees in
commission it was Bill after Bill after
Bill that people said I just can't live
with it
so the original bill here
um
and had to do with uh
um assessing and
payments in lieu of taxes Etc and I
spoke with the prime sponsor she was
going to put a committee onto that bill
and I said well I want to at least add
this
and it just ended up that it was easier
because we have already had that bill
come before both the house decision was
made to go just with the bill
this goes back quite a bit on the to the
language that we had prior to the change
um diff the difference between a
committee and the commission you can see
in the bill that's probably not what
your friends have told you all along
that you know if you want people outside
of the it has to be a commission and if
you don't have people outside it's going
to be a committee well that's
kind of right kind of wrong you can see
what's in the bill again
one of the things that they tried to
accomplish in that is that there would
always be a majority of legislature this
legislative
Representatives on these committees and
commissions
and if you're only limited to 15 people
that means that eight of them if you're
going to have 15 have to be a
legislature from the legislature uh
Senate doesn't want to have that many
people on there uh so we were limiting
us to one which would mean that that
have to be six house members at least
okay
a lot of the people I spoke to in the
house said hey I'm already stretching it
to get here two three days a week
um you know the more committees
commissions you put me on the harder it
is for me to serve
uh so with all that said that's why you
have the bill as amended in front of you
we think it's a reasonable approach
um
and I'll try to answer any questions
somehow I got
dumped the clerk of the house is here
and I hope he speaks in favor of it but
he and I haven't spoken on this bill so
are there any questions from the
committee
thank you madam chairman thank you
senator for your testimony today
um I will say that I am on that
committee for commissions and committees
um there have been other committees for
commissions and committees over the
years and a lot of work has been done to
try to modify this can you please the
practice that is of establishing these
can you please tell me in the Senate
um
is there any
Direction given to Senators say with an
orientation process or anything as to
the number of commissions and committees
um we don't do that kind of thing in the
Senate
certainly it gets to be
self-restricting if you go on and look
at statutory committees for the Senators
those of us that are able to take on
that work have many many okay I'm on the
skyhaven airport Advisory Board I'm the
senate representative to the university
system I'm on the uh Professional
Engineers whatever whatever I'm on
Municipal and County government Finance
I'm on and the list goes on
so that is is why when there is
when your name goes on a bill and it has
a commission in it
um odds are the higher your name is on
that bill the more likely the Senate
President is going to say oh Jim
volunteered for this and so you know we
do try to limit them but there's a lot
of things that we just can't do in one
year there's a lot of things that when
you put them on
a retained bill that they just don't get
the number of people that you need or
the type of people you need and you need
to have people from other things so you
need to to have it to be a commission
again that's you know there is no no
restriction nothing in the training that
I received all those many years ago I
think it was four it must be seven years
since you and I served in the house
yes representative
thank you madam chair hello Senator gray
uh all right so is this bill
um we'll put it in layman's terms I'm a
freshman so I'm trying to read through
this and make sure I understand it
correctly the public is watching as well
on YouTube presumably are you suggesting
or or the the uh the sponsor of this
bill
um what I'm gathering from this language
and maybe you can clarify this is
suggesting that people can be appointed
to these committees or commissions that
are not legislature sure
many subject matter experts uh lobbyists
any of those sorts of people that have
an interest in whatever the committee
serves yes yeah okay and the current
legislation would limit the whole thing
to 15 people
and it also says that it has to be a
majority of legislature legislators on
there okay which would limit the you
know what you can have
um take the solid waste working group
okay uh how many legislators you know
are really up on the you know citing
requirements for landfills how many you
know know the the you know how easy it
is to make methane from food waste how
many know that there's uh
um you know all of the clothing and
different textiles that are put into the
land waste and and how they have to be
done how many know you know what the
price for recyclables both glass and
plastic are I mean you need experts to
do that and you need in in solid waste
working group you need a lot of experts
okay because there's a lot of different
things out there and what we were doing
in the Senate as you were saying
notwithstanding and going into the thing
this revision this is what it's going to
be that was just a waste of my time
follow-up
so how would you imagine that these uh
appointees would be vetted
um to eliminate any sort of bias to kind
of steer these committees towards a
certain outcome like how how would you
um how would you imagine that well
and the way you do it is that in the
bill that sets up the commission or
committee you tell them who is going to
appoint them and certainly my opinion is
you want bias on both sides you want
people who are for this and you want
people that are against it so you know
you may have the Realtors and you may
have the contractors and you may have
you know people from the housing
authority and you may have you know
people from other walks of life so you
want them to be able to represent their
constituency okay and that's how when
you craft the bill that has a committee
in it you say
um
you know the nursing association will
appoint okay the uh whatever you know
and you pick the group that needs to be
represented in there and
public members
appointed by the governor and Council
you know is often a thing that's in
those things uh there's a whole bunch of
things that you do and if you've got one
of those bills
if you don't get it right in the
drafting then all those lobbyists will
come tell you I need to be on that
committee commission I need my group
needs to be represented
Senator I have a question um when you
started your testimony
um you said that you hijacked the bill
and I'm just wondering
um
has the language in this bill that's
hasn't had a public hearing
I don't remember whether I held the
public hearing or not but since the bill
was going to have a committee or
Commission in it and it was in my
committee I ruled it Jermain because it
was dealing with how that committee or
commission would be
put forward but the nice thing is you're
having a hearing right now
and
not a whole lot of attendance because
because these people from uh you know
are probably not going to testify and
I think the only other one you probably
got on your list is is sitting to my
right absolutely
um
I had another question
um as representative wall mentioned
there is a special committee on
commissions that the speaker set up and
um on page one of this bill line 789 it
talks about
study committees being repealed ending
at the filing period or on November 1st
are any of these special committees
commissions that we're going to be
studying and looking at to repeal are
any of these that you're talking about
in your bill
in here that we're going to be looking
at again this is most of that language
that you're reading there is returned to
what it used to be before uh two years
ago okay okay uh so uh you know we don't
want these committees and commissions
you know lasting forever uh so we do
want them to expire or that the
legislature takes action to make sure
that they go beyond I think you look at
their the Committees expire and the
commissions can you know go on beyond
that but again you would go back to the
legislation that created it to see
what's uh what the situation
thank you
and I have just one more question
um the last page of the bill line nine
and ten
um
all commissions shall be
administratively attached to the
appropriate executive branch agency as
determined by the general court
um is there danger in giving these
agencies more Authority than they need
that is actually in there the way I
understand it because that was stuck in
there from one of the AIDS over in the
Senate is that the house no longer
hosts those committees and commissions
here in the state house because of room
availability
and other issues so that most of these
are hosted at one of the department
level you know organizations
Solid Waste working group is held over
on Hazen Drive the assessing Standards
Board which I also sit on is held over
in the hug Allen Park
so again
you don't want to provide the
administrative services and so if you
attach it to one of the Departments out
there and they support it then they'll
fight for it and they'll provide the you
know copying the emailing the all kinds
of things that you don't want to do
okay thank you other oh yes uh rep
constable
thank you madam chair and uh thank you
for taking my question Senator
um on the first page line 10 you have
the establishment of the study committee
and so you don't have the majority being
it doesn't have anything about a
majority but it says shall not exceed 15
members
um it still says shall be limited to
members of the general court only
so are we saying there's no minimum to
the to kick is there one person going to
be appointed to the Committees there's
no minimum yeah you're going to be one
of the ones who decides that when you
pass the Bill uh this I left in there on
a committee because you don't have the
people from other you know departments
Etc so I left that in there to to give
you something that was in the House Bill
2 kind of thing uh and I don't know if
you've you know when you have a a the
whole committee here probably 20 members
20 20 or 21.
um it makes it sometimes more difficult
to get things done
and so I think that was probably why
that was put into that version of the
bill that we're living under now and so
I left that 15 in there for the
Committees not the commissions uh to do
that and you go down below in lines 21
and Below uh that talks about the
commissions and you you I don't believe
that I left in there anything about the
15.
for the commissions yeah okay thank you
representative
chairman and thank you Senator again
um I'm going back to what Chairman's
raised on page two Linens 10 and 9 and
10 rather all commissions shall be
administratively attached to the
appropriate executive branch agency
that's the Departments and agencies over
which we have what we have over 100 of
those here in the state
um who has Authority then over the
committees or commissions rather
I mean who would be in charge are they
are they the ones who will then
administratively be scheduling the
earrings and all how how do you expect
this to work well let's take
um you know either assessing standards
or we'll take uh Solid Waste program
group
um you know the department supplies the
facility where we meet at the department
supplies the administrative Health
um the Committees and commissions I
should say the commissions uh generally
elect their own chair and the chair you
know and the members of the commission
are the ones who usually pick the dates
for the meetings again that has to be
tempered with the availability of the
space in
[Music]
the
Environmental Services they have a
couple of classrooms that they use for
various things and over at DES uh excuse
me over at uh for the assessing
Standards Board
um you know they have one great big
classroom and sometimes that's hard to
get so it's it's a cooperation and again
if if you don't have a department that
is supporting what you're doing for
commission either wanting to make it go
or wanting to make it die
then why did you have one in the first
place I mean
so
but right now because we no longer host
them here uh in the State House you got
to host them somewhere and you don't
have any money to pay for anything uh
who's got the money to pay for a spot
thank you very much Senator all right
I would like to call The Honorable Clerk
of the house Paul Smith and attorney
ciancy
yeah
welcome good morning for the record Paul
Smith Clerk of the house
it for the record excuse me uh house
counsel Jim ciancy
thank you madam chair members of the
committee for I want to clarify a couple
of things
this change that was done last year was
actually in front of this committee as a
standalone bill it was not hijacked into
any House Bill 2 or anything of the sort
House Bill 1269 came to this committee
uh this committee uh worked on the issue
it had two subcommittee work sessions
and was then passed unanimously on the
consent calendar it was sent over to the
Senate where it was referred to Edna and
passed on their consent calendar
and was put into law last year and it
was effective as of September so this
bill is this language is new but it was
done by this committee and for several
reasons
um one of which uh well before before we
get into that
um
the recommendation from us is that you
retain this bill for the short term and
the reason is because we have the
speaker has established a special
committee to examine commissions and
committees and we have to clarify uh
because of questions that have come up
represented possible specifically the
difference between a committee and a
commission we have statutory committees
and then we have commissions which are a
separate thing entirely a study
committee that has been capped at 15
members in this legislation which is is
extremely unusual because study
committees are legislative studies done
by members of both bodies period and
historically those have consisted of not
more than five people and getting those
five people is sometimes a task so
upping that to 15 is going to be nigh
impossible so that is that is something
for consideration in terms of
the specific questions about commissions
and who they were who was appointing
them and and representative McCarter you
asked about uh who's driving the policy
when commissions commissions have gotten
out of hand and one of the the big
um reasons for the the the legislation
that was passed last year was because we
were in possession of two committees
with commissions with 40 plus persons on
them that's insane
the fact of the matter is you're dealing
with Quorum issues more of the time than
you are with actually policy discussion
and driving the issue so this whole
change wholesale change in the stat the
chaptered and statutory committees and
commissions language last year in 1449
was the result of several years of work
that was done by folks like
representative Ebel who had been on the
last committee on committees uh that
that Jen I think has given you your
committee researcher has given you
information on
and the reality is that the way that
this language is crafted here in SB 84
it it does need some work but we're
suggesting that you retain it because
this special committee that has been
established is looking at the totality
of the chapter but also of all of the
commissions and committees as they
currently exist the commissions were
purposely set last term to be not more
than 15 with a majority of legislators
because the folks in its arguably the
house and the Senate at the time felt
that the legislators should be the ones
driving the policy with input from the
public or from other agencies or other
various groups or lobbyists or of that
sort so the fact that this Pat that this
language passed unanimously just last
year by both bodies I I do think speaks
to the intent that we were trying to get
a hold on some of these growing issues
with committees and commissions and I'll
let I'll let Jim answer some of those
foreign
yeah I think it's important to sort of
we talk a lot about committees and
commissions and then it got a bit
confusing trying to differentiate
between them
um and really if you think about sort of
three types of categories and only one
is really a problem and attempted to be
addressed last year and then also with
this bill
um Paul spoke about uh legislator only
studies those are chaptered studies
those are in the first section of RSA
1449 and also in the first section of
this bill and as Paul said generally
those are only four or five members
usually for house one Senate
um though they're staffed by the
legislature legislator only they follow
our house and Senate rules they're
really not an issue and so as Paul
mentioned I think trying to amend that
section of the current law by limiting
them to 15 members
it doesn't do any harm I just don't
think it's necessary because they're I
don't think I've ever seen a chapter
that's got more than four or five
members
um the other type of statutory committee
um which doesn't really present an issue
are what are termed regulatory or
administrative committees or entities
um something like the fiscal committee
or a gel car or the Mount Washington
commission they are creatures of Statute
but they don't really study topics
they're really regulatory in nature they
have a built-in staff whether it's the
legislature LBA or administrative rules
or an outside agency which staffs them
because they really do take on a
regulatory function
what what the 2022 legislation Hospital
1269 and what this bill attempts to do
is address all the other types of study
commissions which are a mix of
legislators and outside members those
currently exist they would exist under
this bill it's
but we really get at the membership and
the governance of those types of
commissions and really the issues are
because there's something of a hybrid
the question is how are they
administered how are they governed
um some have an attachment to the
legislature particularly when they're
chaired by a legislator but when um when
the majority of the membership is
outside members or they're chaired by
outside members really the legislature
kind of loses touch with them and so
some are administered by agencies some
really aren't administered at all and I
think that is the intent of the section
I know there are some questions on page
two about the administrative attachment
um
really what that gets at it's it's not
necessarily a philosophical concept of
of whether the legislature seeding their
Authority it's really about who's going
to administer these things and I think
the intent is I can't really speak to
the intent but my impression is to the
extent that these types of study
commissions are really out exist outside
the legislature even though they have
legislators on them they should be
administered by somebody outside the
legislature whether hosting the meeting
space or running the meetings or writing
the reports
um and and so I think that's an attempt
here
um to sort of
not that they're necessarily executive
branch entities but they do take on sort
of an executive function
um particularly when they get Beyond
sort of the scope of just studying a
topic
um you know I don't know if if that
would necessarily resolve all the
problems but I think it's an attempt to
sort of resolve those administrative and
governance issues and that's why it's
so so with that uh Madam chair members
of the Committees we are um as I said we
are sort of encouraging uh retaining
this bill so that we can work with you
all uh work with our partners on the
special committee uh to by the way that
special committee
um it to members of this committee are
on that special committee uh the vice
chair and and the ranking member are
both on that committee uh and we
um
we are happy to answer any questions and
work with you on this issue thank you
very much are there any questions yes
rep costable
thank you madam chair and thank you
thank you guys for taking the question
um
so do you see retaining this as as sort
of a placeholder for the commission or
why not just why not just in expedient
to legislate at this point so I I think
that you know to the extent that there
might be some discussions uh especially
with with folks from the special
committee about some of the some of the
portions contained in this bill uh that
keeping the vehicle alive uh certainly
um helps and and the collaboration
between this committee and the special
committee
um Can can address some of those issues
uh you know Jim brought up the point of
the administrative attachment again I
think uh and I understand there's been
some questions about that but again I
think that what you're what we need to
look at as as if this is a viable option
putting that in statutes so that I'll
give you an example right now we have
folks that that were put in charge of or
were named first as members of
commissions last year and um you know
the we don't host we couldn't host those
things we can't host those things we
don't have the ability to do like we
used to do and host a myriad of these
commissions and
um so this member uh was trying to call
around to various state agencies willing
to host uh his meeting and the fact of
the matter is if we're going to do that
um
get we it would be helpful if that
exists such that the way future
commissions are created that the
language would say this commission will
be administratively attached to the
Department of Environmental Services
that means that the department has to
provide meeting space
and and a web presence and that sort of
thing right now we list
on our internal stuff our websites and
and that sort of thing we do list all of
the commissions and they're meeting
information as we receive them
um but
you know once that once we they sort of
meet in in elect and that sort of thing
uh unless we hear from them and and get
updates on meetings and that sort of
thing it's
thank you madam chair and thank you
final question
um just on a philosophical sort of
policy
um opinion do you believe that keeping
the majority of legislators as important
on commissions to make sure that the
sort of authority rests in in the
legislature or are you open to
um you know getting rid of the the
majority rule there so I that's that's
I don't want to opine on that um I I
would simply say that that it was the
unanimous opinion of this committee last
term and uh of the house and its
adoption on the consent calendar that
that was
um that that was the preferred way of
handling legislation
um I I very much want to stress that uh
when when people think of of lobbyists
in New Hampshire these are not the kind
of lobbyists that we think of uh in in
other places with you know cigar smoke
and Shady uh Shady dealings
um you know our lobbyists here in New
Hampshire uh have been have been here
for years and decades building
relationships and providing information
so there there is nothing to say that
this was a a slap in any lobbyist face
or organizations face
um but it it in reality it was the
determination by this Committee in the
house that the legislators should be
making the the recommend the majority of
the of the of the group should be
legislators
um receiving input and I would stress as
well that committees study committees
can study the exact same issue
and take input and testimony from the
exact same people that are at the table
as commissions
seeing none
um
and I will close the hearing on Senate
Madam chairman
do you or the chairman himself see any
time in the near future when we might be
working on these or sucking on them do
we know